[Musique]
il pouvait envoyer n'importe quel joueur
pourquoi tu as choisi toi tu me neeman
henry c'était déjà arrivé avant quoi
donc que ton gouvernement cherche à
l'éliminer
non ça c'est nouveau tout ce que nous
avons créées est en danger
n'avais personne capable de tuer henry
brogan gemini va s'en charger mais qui
je crois très cool
moi je peux alors j'ai la recrue idéale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il connaissait le moindre de mes
mouvements à l'avant ce qui sait
je sais pourquoi il est aussi fort que
toi c'est toi gemini se prend pour dieu
en jouant avec l'adn comment c'est
possible quitte à cloner quelqu'un aura
qu clown et nelson mandela
sa demande est là réussir est pas tué un
homme à deux kilomètres dans un train en
marche
il pouvait envoyer n'importe quel joueur
pourquoi es tu as choisi toi parce que
je suis le meilleur
des clairement pas le meilleur vous
voyez pas que la jupe ou ne pose pas de
questions il doit mourir
regarde nous
il te ment depuis le début et c'est de
me déstabiliser non j'essaie de sauver
imaginez que quelqu'un découvre
je connais vraiment toi et moi
[Musique]